yes so Mr sunac initially promised that
he would publish them if he became prime
minister back during the heat of the
Tory party leadership campaign against
Liz truss in the summer of course he's
now been prime minister for about five
months and he's been repeatedly
questioned about it now finally today
the day when most of Westminster was
thoroughly distracted by Boris Johnson's
appearance before the prayer Villages
committee he took his moment to publish
this document now it's not actually a
full tax return as such Nicholas surgeon
did publish her full hmrc document just
last month it's actually a summary of
His income and the tax he's paid I think
the key takeaway really from it as you
might expect really just underlines what
a wealthy man the prime minister is so
in total over that three-year tax period
it shows that he earned nearly 5 million
pounds from a combination of his salary
his Investments and capital gains as
well and over that period as well he
paid just over a million pounds in tax
now one thing that has been highlighted
is that last year for example
um he earned 1.6 million in gains but
paid 325
um 100 000 pounds um in in tax now
there's there's nothing wrong with that
so there's no suggestion of that but
what it is highlighting is that actually
the rate of tax on capital gains is
around 20 so substantially lower what
people would be paying on their salary
now it doesn't give us any information
about the scale of the assets he holds
um some experts have suggested that
given the level of investment income on
the interest perhaps he's holding around
seven million pounds in interest and we
don't have a lot of detail about what
those Investments um all those gains are
we're told that the majority of that
income comes from a blind trust which
critics have have argued means that
effectively we don't know the detail of
where that income is coming from anyway
um now it's also interesting that it's
highlighted in the notes that come with
this document that the Prime Minister
has always been domiciled in the UK for
tax purposes despite the time he spent
living in California which of course is
in contrast to his wife who was born in
India and if you remember the whole
focus on Mr sunac and his tax Affairs
really intensified last year when it was
revealed that his wife who is the
daughter of an Indian billionaire and
has a 0.93 stake in his camp company
emphasis actually
wasn't paying tax on her worldwide
income in the UK despite being married
to the then Chancellor she then changed
tax and said she would be paying tax
um on it but that that was a voluntary
Arrangement so if you're non-dom it
means you don't have to pay tax you just
pay 30 000 pound fee a year it's also
emerged that both of them
um had green cards um until a relatively
recently as well although these
documents says it hasn't affected Mr
sunac's Tax Affairs
um why does this matter well clearly um
it's a time of cost of living crisis
labor often Focus their attacks on the
Prime Minister as being out of tax by
really um stressing how
um very wealthy that he is and this
certainly isn't going to change that
position
um also the very decision taken to
release this information long-awaited as
you say does appear deeply cynical the
liberal Democrats say it was
deliberately designed uh to release it
while everyone was distracted
um by Boris Johnson appearance before
the committee Caroline Lucas of the
green party says it's a naked attempt to
bury the story well I'm sure it's going
to be thoroughly poured over in more
detail by journalists and tax cut tax
experts in the days and weeks to come